zeus che tu puoi scegliere di essere
zeus
io sono a sono zeb ok che bello solo
zeus famiglia no voglio capire un attimo
cos'è questa cosa e cioè io io dove
punto lui spara spara dei dico ecco che
bello questo gioco facciamo bello
ascoltami
cosa ti ho fatto di male perché io non
sapevo di questa cosa bella io non
sapevo di questa di questa cosa stupenda
avvenne nel dio ascoltami qualcosa che
so fare
ti piace si ascolta fratello
sì questo mi sono elettrizzato da solo
che bello senti in attimo non è che io
vorrei ho capito che c'è degli spasmi
mio dio ripigliati scusa devo
assolutamente provare questa gesù gesù
che è bello che è una cosa a me sono
tutti i miei amici ragazzi specialmente
quello perché io sono il dio delle capre
non poter seriamente ma come che io non
sapevo di sa cosa sta cosa bellissima
che potevo fare con la capra zeus e lui
ha deciso che si dispera e bassa ok va
bene rilancio prima scott e ti porto io
guarda vieni con me seguimi 6 immortala
defibrillato di sicuro è viva voglio
vedere ma io sto con la gente così
adesso si elettrizzano guarda quello ha
preso fuoco
a prendere fuoco a ben tre cuocilo dog
ecco bravo hai capito un cazzo di quello
che ho detto ok volta mi non fia non
piangere o ti do io una botta di vita
come si la eco lo qua perfetto stai
sempre messo meglio del tuo amico che
sta sul barbecue è questo te lo devo
dire ma la gara è bellissima volevo
essere zeus nella mia vita almeno una
volta e la roba scendi da quel cazzo di
barbecue amico mio per favore come aveva
passate livello avete mai visto un dio
in bicicletta no perché regala qualche
potreste rimanere stupiti e tu non
parlare al telefono che c'è un dio che
ti passa in bicicletta
ti dispiace sentire col ginocchio perché
mi sono affezionato
ma secondo me li mi spiace perfetto
ragazzi no non cade non perché la gente
[ __ ]
vabbè ragazzi possono vedere che cos'è
la sta roba più che altro per curiosità
voglio provare a fare con un'altra volta
perché era troppo figo e proprio al più
belli in assoluto ovunque zeus vince
tutto ragazzi questo è sicuro giuro che
non lo so come ho fatto a non scoprirlo
prima però è bellissimo
sarà che proviamo con qualcos'altro tipo
abbiamo fatto magician facciamo non
facciamo or wrong facciamo robbie hunter
hunter che pesca che bello mi fate
vedere quali sono le mosse dell'inter
che non l'ho ancora visto cos'è questo
io non pensi pesce li lancia il pesce
giusto quindi la vita su una mette mette
i pesci per cento del tasto r che
casuali pesca o ovvio i pescatori sono
dei pesci che prendono quelli che avevo
già una roba beh allora lanciano pesci
perché sono bello khartoum idioti grassi
un flash e tv lml giusto ecco la
perfetta
mi sa che la gravità forse puzza un
posto pesce perché sono emma non sarebbe
morto se non che per vendere il pesce
tiva se compri qualcosa ci mettiamo
d'accordo e non mi venire ascoltati
niente lui viene sulle mele anche venuto
con la mela
ascoltami niente allora ti porto in
pescheria lui piace il pesce per caso se
il pesce è bello eh no niente neanche a
lei piace il pesce era lei lo vuole un
po di pesce le niente nessuno piace il
pesce capitan findus ragazzi qualche chi
è questo tizio che cazzo vuoi ragazzi
credo di aver sottovalutato il potere
del pesce la cosa più bella che abbia
mai visto una ragazza temi vedere cosa
c'è in giro perché non c'è l'ultima chi
cazzo fai tu ragazzi pensi gratis per
quest'uomo che fa il bla ecco è morto
dovevo farlo che fa erano si è spostato
giusto perché erano troppo morbidi se
devi morire mi così inutile che cosa fai
che cazzo di calpestio o un rock ed io
posso pescare anche le capre che cazzo
fanno questi posso pescati di è coesa
ho preso una capra ragazzi la mia vita è
fottutamente come la vuoi una capra l'ha
uccisa così cioè io ho trovato un nuovo
[ __ ] sport
cosa ha fatto cavallo p vieni tu qua
cavallo no no no non ti azzardare cazzo
fai vieni qua dove vai lontano dai
bastardi ma dove vai dove vai
vieni qui cosa fa ascoltami francia e
fai i famosi cavalli acquatici lega il
cazzo è successo e ragazzi sono rimasti
casa [ __ ] vieni qua ecco l'ho
fatta sono dentro un porta come fatte
entrare in un portale da dove cosa mi
rappresenta
voglio lei suceava il tool e next r come
tra dove porta sta roba non lo so non ha
minato prima di andarci voglio vedere il
cavallo di prima basta vieni costo vieni
qui vieni qua dove cazzo 20 gatti giunti
lancio un uomo ti lancio santi fermo e
dei vari morir l'ho mancato riguarda
terminati o che più una capra c'è lancio
della madonna è un piatto speciale
questo capra con pesci è una cosa buona
tuo cavallo stronzo fermati vabbè
andiamo a vedere se gli scoraggiarmi con
una corona
ecco questo sopra godo devo lanciarmi
con la ecco cos'è mio dio cazzone vulcan
e vabbè dai il vulcano sara gentile con
te sono convinto tanto son finito sulla
montagna fantastico ascoltami zia poi
puoi farmi vedere dove si va ho preso un
martello scusami nuvola ma vede non lo
mangia sulle sul tetto che ascolta
fratello sky non è capace al suo ok ok
io io ragazzi voi non lo sapete ma io
sono un mago
faccio magia il mercoledì al martedì
meno sapete se ti va di andare sulla
barca che ecco esatto no no no grazie
messeri visto che mi sono la mia mano
che ci stiamo tutti e due come nel
titanico uguale no no no
[Musica]
ma devo ancora capire dove si accusa
perché la gente in questo posto prende
fuoco a dove ma veramente la gente si
diverte così in quest'anno alla
ascoltami sia il mio paese cioè altri
passatempi e non è che facciamo tutti i
kamikaze coattiva di prendere un po
fuoco anche tu frate hai visto zio che
ti ho chiamato frater non solo nasce un
rapper cosa stai godendo conta gandalf
hai per caso no niente è morto anche
quando con che ragazzi io ancora devo
capire cosa cosa è successo perché devo
capire che cosa ci sta a fare una
fattoria di mucche geneticamente aliena
perché sparano laser dalle mammelle fair
spiegate in un senso di questo
videogioco ragazzi non si va a casa ecco
pescato la mucca aliena fantastica la
fattoria di mucche mutanti ragazzi mi
mancava e credetemi ancora non avevo
vista che cazzo e hanno tirato un calcio
da madonna e sono finito dietro le
montagne fantastico che bug che figo
cioè io posso uscire di qua mica che
bello
ho vinto ho vinto gozzi volerne dove
sono la mia fonte sono tornato
all'inizio [ __ ] lega che cos'è
cioè il re mucca ascoltami remo eh vabbè
ma anche due [ __ ] è che cos'è
lo so prendere contesa c'è qua dentro il
tesoro del r'n'b un cut posso pure posso
aprire questa è la vera 8 il cazzo ok
una donna oppure ho preso ore molti
ragazzi in ritirata entra eccoci qua ci
siamo attori indietro trova il travel
perfetto ragazzi belli o portatore mucca
nel dove mi è sparito remo che va bene
peccato è stato è stato bello ragazzi ho
pescato gandalf come si deve perché
voglio portarlo a fare un giro in barca
perché è tremendamente sexy gandalf in
questo gioco l'altro scusa fratello non
volevo deco esatto per noi non è non è e
gandalf lui e albus silente il grigio
c'è una fusione tra gandalf el preside
di hogwarts è fantastico
l'ex preside di ntt ecco braccio i
commenti di comodo non ho ben capito
ragazzi che cosa li devo fare un cazzo
morirà così ragazzo è stato un bravo
ragazzo
carrara ragazzi sta musica e fantastico
corso c'è un orso qua dentro valor sono
e questo sarebbe un [ __ ] corso odio
questi orsi li odio così tanto uccisi
per me lo farò zio lo fa ecco non lo
farò più perché ti ho ucciso io li butta
tutto il gioco si va a 1200 dove lo
lancia o mio dio
ok è tra l'altro ok per chi sei pregando
zio della mini come ravo allora vedi
questo che sta scavando la tomba tutti i
mezzi no scusami o non volevo c'è un
funerale che cazzo in molti è che è
morto gas deve essere gara ghazi khan
dal pesce il funerale di un pesce ok
tutti parliamo qualcuno nella vita io lo
so però ti totti deco every profeta il
vedi che ancora si può ritrovare il
sorriso che c'era in questo pesce è vero
donne inesatto d'accordo ragazzine che
fu ucciso a mezza popolazione con una
transenna
direi che posso concludere qui ma non
prima di essermi fatto un altro giro
sulla scopa perchè lo sanno tutti che io
a 15 sono meglio di harry potter uno che
sa cosa della scoperta geniale guarda
che lo prendi pieno ma l'europa può più
c'è una mira che mio zio mia nonna
farebbe di meglio ma vabbè concluso per
avvisati ragazzi spera veli sia piaciuto
il gameplay con la il pescatore che in
teoria dovrebbe essere cacciatore ma il
pescatore va bene niente ragazzi se il
vino è piaciuto perché si deformano
tutti i said on ma si trattano così le
persone ecco infatti molla l'osso perché
prima che diventi più strano sto gioco
concludo qualche meglio se video è
piaciuto ma senza lasciate un commento
mi piace anche a pacelli facebook e come
non divido tra ten descrizione se avessi
di sfilate ci vediamo al prossimo video
delle ragazze e smettila di scavare che
palle